this program is brought to you by
Teachers College Columbia University
please visit us online at iTunes TC
columbia edu
Oh
thank you hi everyone um when this
opportunity was offered to me in the
spring I was excited because when i
first started a program i wanted to do
something in something in jamaica on and
you know what that something was but on
you know this this this popped up I went
to Jamaica in July of 2008 and I go back
to Jamaica every year and I go back as a
tourist and this time I went down there
and I wasn't really a tourist that dated
for four weeks and it felt it felt very
different you know I went down here and
you know I met with these I thought to
myself how am I gonna um interact you
know like I'm speaking on my to Lulu you
know sneaky sneaky spoken and when I was
down and i met with the people there
like look at me like speak in Papua when
you're speaking to us that's okay um so
I went out and I got together these
people to do the focus group my cousin
who lives in Jamaica was very helpful in
this endeavor I didn't know how I would
get the people but I think it was my
uncle sesame if you wanna be a lawyer
dr. Webber in Jamaica seat oh boy so
thank you boy and we got me these people
so i'm i'm going to move forward and
give you some background information on
the hiv/aids epidemic in Jamaica as you
can see it's estimated that 230,000
people are living with HIV in Jamaica
and 20,000 people are you
I'm going to skip this this whole
background thing and talk about my
experiences there on the main modes of
transmission in HR in Jamaica is
unprotected heterosexual intercourse on
and also sex between men although it's
it's something that's Sean upon in
Jamaica all right let me go back I'm
sorry okay the estimate that i gave you
before I'm sorry is 230,000 people in
the Caribbean so that's Caribbean wire
in Jamaica its twenty two thousand
people so 1.5% on people but also living
with hiv/aids in Jamaica I'm sorry bear
with me i'm confident balance i I show
these two pictures of Jamaica because
what I went to Jamaica I saw people who
live in houses like these and I saw
people who lived in houses like those
and but I said two different worlds one
island because the theme was the same
throughout um people living in homes
like these and people have been in homes
like those and I'm going to go through
some of those themes and I man and this
is the inner city of Jamaica and
Kingston places where I want to see
people to do these focus groups on let
me backtrack because I let me give you
some information about my my experience
when I went dahlia it's um it was it was
very
very emotional you know going to Jamaica
and talking about hiv/aids and going
down you're thinking how how can I help
my people get education around hiv/aids
without sounding like I'm forcing
something onto them and that was
something that I had to sit back you
know maybe a night or two before I went
off in and see them and when I went to
meet with them I i guess i was song i
felt like i was i was removed and I
didn't want to remove myself from them I
wanted to be a part of them and seek
with them so speaking in a whole
possible thing what a connection what a
connection to the people and they were
they became very open and very engaged
when I started speaking to them in
Baltimore so I what this matter them
that I'm going to skip this the slides I
wasn't matter with me and I sat down and
a half them look at this menu I'm trying
to implement something in Jamaica that
will provide education around HIV on
transmission using appears so they are
look at the manual you know Jamaicans
say that they love to read so given them
a manual for like five minutes of 10
minutes to look out wasn't doing
anything I had to give them the manual
how them sit there and read it they
resume and they have a lot of questions
there's questions around HIV on AIDS
transmission there's questions on about
the whole the whole clinical piece I
mean they really wanted to know about
HIV transmission I was down before that
for weeks I saw a lot of information
around HIV there was a lot of cultural
on campaigns and I thought well with all
this information going on around you
make a wire are they asking so much
about HIV it's out there it's there but
they weren't for some reason there was a
disconnect between the campaign
information is being given and
information that the my participants
have so with that some of the themes why
I identified a lot of themes but for the
purpose of this conference I will focus
on four of those themes
happy
yes
Oh
okay sorry okay so i did a somatic
analysis based on results of the focus
groups like i said and i identified four
themes for the purpose of this
conference I saw and when I saw 43 on
people for this focus group for there
were 43 on participants and when I went
down initially i was looking at women
but while i was doing a focus group men
became interested and they wanted to be
part of this focus group so i had most
of the participants were female but i
have a large chunk of milk in this focus
group and adults for interviews so the
things that i identified word negative
associations held towards HIV positive
individuals recognition of stigma and
behavioral practices in place to make
ends at risk for HIV and or STD so as
you can see on one participant said once
somebody sees you at the comprehensive
clinic they say yes you have AIDS
because it's an AIDS clinic and this is
I believe the only HIV AIDS clinic and
Kingston Jamaica so although it's a it's
perceived as an HIV AIDS clinic it
offers other services or people will not
go there on for other services because
they fear that if you go there for
anything people are going to think that
you have HIV and AIDS and then another
participants and if you have HIV and
AIDS and you sit right there nope and
I'm seeking in Papua Papua nobody ever
going to sit there and because the
phobia is whether or not it's sexual
smita to them are to us sitting there it
goes straight in their skin meaning it
goes directly into your skin so if you
sit in a spot where do you think someone
has HIV any believe that it's you're
going to get it you know there's no
clear explanation how are you going to
get it but just sitting there you're
going to get HIV and needs recognition
of stigma but you know it's somebody
tells you that they are HIV positive and
you right just take away at you you
right away just take for yourself you
movie meaning you move yourself away you
know that's prejudice so this is in
response to the person stayed in that if
she or he sits there you're going to get
HIV there's somebody recognizing that if
you say this it's a prejudice and
although there are there these stigma
that they have it's also a recognition
that it's that it's um they're
stigmatizing spawns so which is good
behavioral practices that place
Jamaicans at risk for HIV infection and
this is another one some high-risk
situations on some Jamaican men believe
that some high-risk situations that are
specific to Jamaica is some Jamaican men
believe that they must have plenty woman
yelling of uncle and then was riding
bareback because that is nice a condom
cut the fun basically it's a cultural I
won't say cultural belief but maybe it
all and i'll even also if it's a i would
say our normal practice in jamaica and
it's a practice here in the states those
not just the Jamaica but men having
multiple women and it's that's our mode
of transmission having you know it
having multiple partners having multiple
partners puts them at risk but the
belief that having men just feeling I
guess macho that they have more than one
women is something that they do and then
right there back meaning that when they
have these woman and have sex there is
no condom use so bareback as long what's
the terminology and I believe it's a
terminology here as well um so um you
know like I said there are plenty of
other themes that they came up but this
is for like I said for the purpose of
this conference I just all chose to
focus on these few um and it's this is
the formative stage actually came up and
she spoke about her work in Togo and
this the end result having the festival
and all that stuff the goal is to once I
obtain this information hopefully go
down and do something like that in in
Jamaica um conclusion on participants
recognized the importance of reducing
HIV AIDS and stigmatization around
persons with HIV and AIDS um it was very
very clear in all the focus groups that
they crave our knowledge for
understanding not just HIV transmission
but the disease itself I'm I remember
the disease itself and also different
modes of transition in sitting in one of
the focus group you know uh one of the
participants and I were going back and
forth talking and if you listen to the
recordings you might think that we're
arguing but we weren't arguing her her
she was so strong in her point she
wanted to know about the relationship
between HIV and bleach and in the manual
it talked about intravenous drug use and
using bleach to clean the nail on the
syringe
if you don't have a choice to use
another one and she sent to me so you
mean you mean Lisa if if you're going to
you by bleach that bleach is going to
kill the HIV and I'm saying to her no
it's it's a way to UM minimize the
transmission but she wanted me I felt
like she wanted me to say bleach kills
HIV and I I couldn't go up there and say
that I a setter i'm not an expert so she
goes on and then she said okay and she
wanted to know about the transmission of
the breast milk the maternal breast milk
on to the baby who took to the newborn
baby and I told her well that's a a mode
of transmission and you know just going
through stuff like that and really
explaining to her um was something that
was important in it you know they craved
that um so you know from there I really
believe there's a need for prevention
programs that really considers on the
individual where the individuals is at
and also cultural barriers that are
prevents them from properly on you know
proper behavior management that's it
thank you
so I know thank you visa are any
questions for Lisa of upper work in
Jamaica could you just maybe describe
some of the different settings that she
went into the garrison vs yeah where she
went into I went in Jamaica um they have
it's the difference between the garrison
and the ghetto the garrison was told to
me they told me that the garrison is a
place where um it's more violent prone
and gang-related and have been in a
ghetto it's just more of an economical
situation for not having money and stuff
like that and I actually went into the
garrison it was my very very first time
going into the garrison and when you go
into the garrison is usually one way in
and one way out um I went there maybe
around eight o'clock at night with
someone who is from the garrison and
speaking with them it was it was I was a
little bit nervous but it was an
enjoyable experience the people there
made me feel welcome um they they asked
a lot of questions they first arm for
information about HIV and AIDS and it's
so funny that that one on meeting we had
a group of people on talking to me and
one guy he came over and he wanted to
participate in a focus group but he just
kept standing to the side and I kept
saying oh come on over you could
participate and then I see another guy
walks away and said that he's not
participating so I said okay ask at the
end of the focus group the guy came over
and he said to me and again in Papua
virgen de novo read so I stepped aside
meaning his friend does not know how to
read and because he didn't want to hurt
his friend's feelings he stepped out of
the arm the focus suit but his friend
was able to hear what we were saying
when he
unable to relate any information about
the manual because he couldn't read
that's kind of questions so great for
you that you did an assessment of
cultural assessment to see how a model
and fit in a culture that's beautiful so
given what we just saw in such a
beautiful presentation of all the steps
and the different modules what is your
impression now of the one set with the
components that would work and not
working how they would be a death okay
um I see this working in jamaica on
similar to the people in Togo Jamaicans
long music and I see there was a lot of
music and theater and if a peer educator
can go down there and provide
information through skits on through
some dance on counter minds on which are
on place that Jamaican so too is spelled
with a lot of humor it's something like
this were to be done in Jamaica yes this
can be implemented on down there okay Oh
immersion ears
I find myself having to speak or engaged
differently between
climate women may mean I wanted to have
any employee share present or vice versa
was it just no gender barriers there
wasn't any gender or sexual berries in
there the women were very vocal in terms
of HIV transmission over the guys um but
no there there wasn't any any
differences at all I didn't notice any
differences you know they said what they
wanted to say asked questions and that
was it what the guys dig agree um I
would like the female about the whole
apartment stuff you know and joke them
all in all though they were joking about
it they said that it wasn't a good thing
to do okay well we're just actually the
harlot Lisa that you were able to go to
Jamaica to do this project we're
delighted that you were calm centered
and balanced and we really appreciate I
mean I think one of the things of the
people that all of you I asked you to
appreciate is the extent to which of her
of transcribing her team's is not
necessarily easy task it's almost she
won't be having to translate from fat
bob into English so it's a very
time-consuming process and she has a lot
of things but we really want to
congratulate her on the first a face of
her projects let's get her
okay so we don't have shown since who
this is this is a student who really
embodies a mission to be a health
educator in partnership with the
faith-based community so from the very
first day that Sharon arrived she was
informing us that you know how am I
going to take information to my church
how am I going to be able to continue to
build on the opportunity to the church
is made available to me and as the
health educator I want to do as much as
I can to assist my church's mission so
she's a part of a church that takes
annual trips to Africa and so she was
able to go to with him in August 2008 to
Kenya and I was able to give her the
smallest amount of money the money that
I had but she maximized it and let's see
what she discovered in terms of a
cultural adaptation that's possible when
she returns again in terms of taking the
manual and doing something in Kenya over
a longer period of time this she was
elated for two weeks good afternoon
everywhere
she's also okay good afternoon once
again everyone thank you so much for
coming close presentation the
presentation is entitled summer 2008
experience in Nairobi Kenya and I put
field notes because this is exactly what
i did i documented notes from the field
and you'll see the you'll see the
summary of the notes kenya kenya is
located in east africa it has a
population of approximately 37 million
people and they're about 1.3 million
people they're living with HIV and AIDS
and annually they are 60,000 new HIV
infections and 130,000 people receive
antiretroviral therapy so look at the
number of people who receive therapy and
the number of people who are living with
AIDS there's a huge difference this
picture over here is infected accept
your status change and live positive
life I saw that at a school so I decided
to take a picture of that which I was
happy about the same way nairobi um I
visited well we were suppose I suppose
conduct focus groups in Mombasa and
Nairobi because this summer I had the
opportunity to go with my church so the
Mombasa in my movie but it was not
possible to conduct the focus group am I
in mailboxes so all focus groups for
well normally is a capital of kenya it's
the second largest city in Kenya and
fair about three to four million people
in Nairobi I'm you'll see a few pictures
of different sizes in Nairobi Kenya
itself is quite beautiful Nairobi is a
beautiful place just a beautiful place
but there are so many differences like
Lisa said in Jamaica there are just so
many differences in my movie in general
information professor Wallace spoke
about the past my past missionary
experiences there the whole church
there's the London life worship center
and we've established a really great
relationship with them so my first trip
there with my church with the missionary
team for my church was in 2004 my second
trip 2006 and then this past summer in
2008 they will all short-term missionary
trips the first ones just one week the
second two weeks and this last two weeks
um and when you go on the missionary
trip before each person these were given
a role we're given in assignments and my
role my service health educator so I
went there the first time with my health
education on knowledge and I try to
conduct the presentation on HIV and AIDS
in one of the slum communities and some
of the people just got up big and walks
away I had an idea live but then someone
explained to me that when people just
don't want to discuss aids there and if
people realize that they are infected
where they have the disease they don't
have the money for the tree
so it doesn't even make any sense so to
them it was a waste of time listening to
me and I had a lot to learn so I'm glad
that I actually had this opportunity
this past summer to certain fill out the
focus groups we had a chance not this
past summer but the summer before to
visit um kaveri which is a second
largest slum in africa and it's not
community unfortunately i don't have a
picture of a slum community the small
community has homes that are right next
to each other and when I say homes I
mean a one-room of one wheel in dwelling
with roofs that are tin roofs an entire
family lives will live there the sewage
you just see sewage the source there is
no sewage system there so on a really
hot day this the stench is horrible um
and then you have so many people
dwelling in that community and you
wonder why why I mean there's so many
questions there and our purpose as a
part of the mission team the medical
mission team sets up camps when we go to
these differences on communities and we
have just one big cans where people will
line up literally from early in the
morning before we get there and they
will wait until summer until they can be
seen so their minimum available
resources so this is what we're working
with fair in Kenya in the slum
communities so disease prevention is
vital they cannot afford to pay for
medication they cannot afford treatment
so prevent the disease the objectives of
this particular project was to allow
focus group participants to review the
hiv/aids care education training
annual dr oz's manual the second
objective was to determine if the
hiv/aids peer education program would be
feasible for implementation in Nairobi
Kenya and the third objective was to
learn of modifications needed to make
the manual more culturally appropriate
for the population of interest the
methods including well I conducted for
focus oops the participants were
revealing female the part of the
inclusion criteria of the participants
were male and female who are over the
age of 18 and who are able to
communicate in English they were able to
read English write English onion
understand how I speak english and i say
that because during the first focus
group there were two participants and
they were not able to say because they
could not understand my english they um
and I don't speak swahili swahili is the
main language there so and this was the
requirement and i am informed those who
helped me to secure the people for the
focus group that they need to be able to
understand how i speak on the
recruitment site the recruitment side
was the clinic now you see this
compassionate medical clinic that wasn't
there in 2004 this is the clinic that
actually belongs to the church once we
when we arrived there and we took we
provided medical supplies and we gave
them the donations they also are sorry
aren't to the vision and they were able
to secure funds to build a metal
and with us obvious a small clinic I
mean you see the picture below is the
clinic itself so the entrance and the
planet so people were recruited from
that area and from the medical camp
participants we had a medical camp there
so they were total of twenty-two
participants 17 females in five minutes
there are about 12 focus group questions
but I decided just to concentrate on
four questions for this presentation so
the first question that i'd like to
share it and respond and some of the
responses are do you think this kind of
hiv/aids training program would work or
being affected in your community so some
of the responses are here yes it will
work it will show us how to protect
ourselves this information will prevent
death in this country it will be
effective because it is for young people
the young people will spread what they
learn and that was a thing that they
spoke about the many but horrible the
four focus groups all the participant
bears all mentioned the youth and making
sure that the youth would be involved in
a project such as this and also if there
is a message showing that there is a way
out then people will want to hear it
people will spread the information the
second question that I want to share is
modification that are needed for a more
culture for in order the manual to be
more culturally appropriate on they they
are recommended that we
pictures of people with AIDS people
dying people suffering from AIDS and
matches okay they said then they would
understand you know the importance of
prevention so that I might as well
famine and also to travel through met
the manual it's a Swahili and French
those are the two common languages
spoken in that particular area many
people speak English because English is
required they the students are required
to learn English but the older people
don't know English for the most part
there are 42 tribes 22 languages and
ideally it would be nice to have this
have the manual translated into
twenty-two languages possible they also
spoke about making an age of credit and
age-appropriate manual available manual
for children because there's so many
children and when we go there we see
children running up and down so be real
it would be really good for us to have a
manual for children one modification and
I decided to include it here is one of
the picture was the hand registers gets
used that is used in the book they said
that it would be very offensive so
that's not a hand gesture that could be
used for them it's the pick up the
middle finger pointing down said people
could start fighting and usually it's
fun to us and they said it could be a
curse so that they definitely could not
use that hand gesture um the next is a
cultural beliefs and then the next
person involved cultural beliefs what
cultural beliefs practices and behaviors
on need to be addressed so on the left I
listed some of the release and the right
practices and behaviors the first belief
is that HIV positive if HIV positive
older men um has tests with small
children then they are cured from the
disease the second belief or another
belief is that
fish prevents getting of the disease
this is the first time I've heard this
but I thought it was interesting and
AIDS is witchcraft now in the
communities there the slum communities
people have access to the witch doctor
so this is a part of the community so
for somewhere to believe that it's
witchcraft fits income and raising them
right so that's definitely a belief that
has to be has to be discussed and has to
be dealt with I'm some of the practices
involved both taken which involves blood
on anal anal sex and oral sex no the
gentleman who mentioned or we spoke
about this as a young man and he when he
mentioned there's someone else said oh
no no no but this is something that he
thought was important for the youth
actually thought about the female
circumcision which is the traditional
circumcision the rights rights of
passage and they spoke about speaking to
the senior ladies or the grandmothers
about this tradition and maybe even
telling them where in front of them
about using clean using clean tools and
the last is which actually spoke about
also his wife inherited a cadet
husband I didn't realize that but
actually already spoke about that so the
next question that I would like to
address the next customer is um that
steps steps that need to be taken to
make an hiv/aids prevention care
education training program work in the
community so what steps to do they need
to take they spoke about incorporating
the program in schools and churches now
the schools and churches because there
are so many people who gather in the
schools together in the churches so that
both it would be good to incorporate
broke the program into those two areas
also once again to empower the youth
with finances and train them to deliver
the message now empower the youth with
finances is important because many of
them are unemployed some people are
living on less than two dollars to
united states united states dollars per
day so they definitely would like for
the youth for the youth to be financed
and empower them to train and deliver
messages and in delivering on the
messages like what athletes presentation
was the music when we were there when we
were there we passed young people who
were having they were it wasn't a party
it's like a concert so they had concert
and they said that that's something
that's come in there they love together
they love to have the music and listen
to the music and they're really really
talented so that would definitely be
it will definitely get involved leaf
also involving parents and teachers and
to talk to groups now the parents and
the teachers I saw some of the parents
say what that the medical capsule would
be it would definitely be good to
involve them and the teachers it was
actually a teacher in one of the focus
groups and he said that it would be good
for him to share this information with
his classes with his students another
thing is to get HIV positive people to
educate others if I have the disease
that I'm infected then I can share my
story so they saw that would be powerful
and also to speak the language of the
people who died young speak and they
understand that they are very gracious
they all speak to me in English so
that's good but for whoever is would be
responsible for ensuring that this
program takes place to make sure that
the language of the people will be
spoken in conclusion louses 2005
hiv/aids care education program is
feasible for implementation in Nairobi
Kenya they actually wanted me to leave
the manuals with them so that they can
read the manuals and they complained
that
not give them enough time to review the
manual as long Lisa commented because
when I said okay you know what we're an
entire schedule I wasn't I'm just my
schedule that I had to be on the time
schedule on the missionary team and he
said well we need to leave here at a
certain time so and I also had to do my
work there for the missionary team so
giving them the manual I'm just getting
going few minutes to look at the menu to
review it they did not think it was
sufficient time and they were really
involved in the process of the focus
group the second point here is that
cultural beliefs and behaviors must be
addressed if this program will be
implemented in kenya's they must be
addressed we cannot just implement the
program and forget about the cultural
beliefs and on the behaviors otherwise
the program will not be effective and
this program has the potential to
decrease the rate of new HIV infections
since since many people don't have the
resources to even buy food at times then
definitely disease prevention definitely
would be the key because then they would
not have to worry about paying for
medication or trying to get medication
and even when we're at the medical
clinic and they and some of the people
really need to go to the hospital or
whether they consider to be the hospital
they don't have texting money and we
don't give them too taxing my soul
actually take them there because if we
were told that if we give them taxi
money bill taking my food they will not
go to the doctor so and the picture here
that you see these are children work on
a key and the church this is not in this
little
community I didn't conduct the focus
group in the slum communities in any of
the slum communities because this time
we had the medical clinic and the church
now people from the small communities
will walk very far to get anything that
they need to get so we're offering three
services they will walk very far that's
what they do and they will wait all day
so definitely this will be a good
program to implement there and I told
them that I will be back next summer so
hopefully that will be possible for me
to return sorry this summer's increment
this program out like definitely took on
acknowledge who hasn't Martin was the
research with my disparities and health
the abundant life worship center team
there in Kenya the missionary team here
at my church on to the Bethesda healing
center and none will sponsor for my
church who are collected and thank you
this is my mom and I at the airport
Mohammed sitting in the back who she
starts at she works as a nurse there on
the medical missions to thank you
so we return to that theme of pride I
think Lisa is your mother you too okay
so we just want to congratulate our
mothers and just say how about we are
amazing your mother's also that they
believe in service to their communities
and I'm doing my best to polish them up
okay so now we have questions ok
questions dr. Judy oh I'm so impressed
good for you amazing actually questions
one is I'm very impressed with the
concept of blindness to children because
clearly you have to deal with the whole
community so what are your thoughts
about what are the components that could
be put in and headed in to address
children and my second question has to
do with the sustainability of the
program which actually relates also to
the fact that you implemented it in toto
so after the four weeks and what comes
after that inserts out as a first
question in terms of the manual having
the manual or adopting certain parts of
the manual for children it definitely
can be done anything that any
information that we t we know how to or
it can be broken down to the
and the children they are very
intelligent children they literally sit
there and listen to what they said they
ask questions and they respond and this
is based on my observations from the
vacation practicing programs that are
held there while we are there so as long
as we are able to select parts that we
think are pertinent it definitely can be
modeled for the children sustainability
of the program they have the vision
there and what I didn't mention is that
I'm a part of the clinic includes a
voluntary counseling and testing center
which was that was put the ring last
year I think baby had I think the
government gave them money to have that
long-term confident testing center so as
long as the people who want something to
continue it will happen we were told
after we left the last time that based
on a woman's based on a woman's of what
proved of woman met and my pastor spoke
to them once we return they got together
that money together and purchased a bus
or something to get around to those
different groups of women to speak so
once they have a vision to accomplish
something
accomplished it so if this is something
that they want to sustain then people
are willing to arms here when we go
there each summer people volunteer we
have they meet us at the airport they
volunteer to translate for us and
there's one gentleman there after he has
been tremendous since 2004 before we get
there he makes sure that everything is
set up I'm really well so that was once
we get there our transition is smooth he
is when I thought to ask her about my
emails Oscar about conducting the focus
suit and he said okay he would make sure
that um you know that I'd be able to
took enough folks who say and you know
he had a death in the family violence
there he still made sure that someone
else was their response was responsible
enough to make sure that there are
people that are able to hold the focus
groups so that they just need money to
continue yes but if they want to
volunteer I know that they do and you
think that's just how they are then they
will definitely continue that program oh
I have an fine okay dr. Samuels
apologies we're going to see you should
know that doctor should be in castor was
not able to be here today to do some
work alba nations so when i figure of
her project and Haney I let's see with
an r you can do in just five minutes oh
well I saw stereo okay oh good evening
everyone my name is Alberta and I come
from India the nation's that gave like I
told you last year kamasutra of the
world and more recently slumdog
millionaire how do you see
yeah we're after the Oscars okay the
slum dog is actually set in a sister of
slum in Mumbai 3 and the next second
that I did was set in a slum in New
Delhi India which is the capital of the
country but just quickly I will run you
through a few facts about my country for
those of you who are not familiar with
India we are more than 1 billion people
strong that means one in every six human
beings on this earth isn't in game so
and we just have about 14 official
languages couple thousand I legs and a
couple of other challenges that we go
we're not even aware off and not to the
tech person having a technician okay so
um then quickly walk you through some
packs like I said we have to provide
within people who are estimated to be
HIV positive just keep your heads up the
signal was revised in 2007 by the
National a support organization before
that is fine point 1 billion people
strong and I'm talking about we I
thought at one point we were that game
is really increasing very fast the
estimated percentage of people are
living in Chinese is between your 20.2
and point five percent the primary route
of transmission in India is heterosexual
contact and it reads drug use and the
next i will show you the different
percentages and the highest populations
are for india include commercial sex
workers long-distance truck drivers who
are are now playing a role in
transmitting this infection to different
parts of india hitherto not even touched
Fred this infection and introduced
reduces to the problem in the north
northeast of the country so that is like
today when getting a percent
basically through sexual contact and i
will quickly give you a perspective we
are sending to South Africa cause of the
oral numbers and if you look at if you
break down in terms of the number of
people once again one-third of the
infected population includes women which
is reason why we want to focus on women
that's another little bit of work in
English prisons and from my work that I
I figured you know I came to conclusion
that a lot of women half of the slum
areas and form of maneuvers villages so
we wanted to when I saw professor was
about of the local health of project
idea I you know profess it worked allow
you to work with this operation is very
very just allow that to happen so
quickly i'm going to give you like the
power overview of dairy like i said i
still be New York we beat you up in
terms of the number of people sent email
we do oh great my pepper to my camp okay
so you fight back here about five and
seven per square miles in terms the area
published at least 30,000 people per
square mile and believe me that is
overpopulated the first location that we
that I rented if I focus to him was the
urban slum called jahangirpuri which is
a lot like what you saw in some Darmody
there and a lot like what sherry decide
to do there's also exists in the sewage
flowing on the road um if you can call
our own and go debunking either during
some it's not the place that you that I
you feel that I you think anyone if you
can work in because it really sells it
really says it's really hard electricity
that you struggle for us over there so
give I admire people who can who live
there really and the second location was
in the south west of Delhi below is
green portion it was a bottom village
called Nagas
two new village so I guess must be
really stylish it's on the border of hi
Jana and dairy I'm gonna rush it so I
would have told you more about 30 but
you know I just invite you all to visit
me in there ok so there is quickly walk
you through the books through
discussions we did we interviewed 40
women and Carson profiles gently 18 to
60 years old I had night and I'm arguing
with very illiteracy levels which means
that i had the vegetable seller with not
really you have sign my name and then i
had people who have a master's in class
and then i had people who were community
health workers in the urban slums and i
have students and the rural village the
village that I went through and
absolutely Vanessa most of India's very
patriarchal we don't normally allow
everybody to work and I see that he was
to be like in my village set up the
community that I work with worked with
was the last food community and they are
very strong and protecting the women
they do not want them to work at all two
minutes budgeting ok so just quickly
walk you through what is happening um
they do know about hiv/aids so they
don't have details so we need to do this
program day it is not female condom
they're extremely curious i professor
Wallace our collaboration for adding
that bitch to the manual says I the demo
with the mango about the female body
with no very excited about it they said
ladies cannot teach men because of this
care of patriarch of the vibe that we
have and also because I'm afraid of the
reputation one can I think that you know
talk about sex I don't know me the
figure has because that I know particle
focus oops he also complained about
situations where you know men tend to
harass them by you making capital asset
Russell that something had to be with
men you know the sacrament unit you I
even has a try mr. country why my man my
husband may not end up respecting me as
much when I get back home that's the
general impression that women have over
there also they present married women as
fear experience were sourced more
equipped to talk about sexual practices
and you know they will be with each
other or remain in the community or not
nerdy and calculor let them grow up what
is from crushing and what is it that the
one reviews of dr. FC just material they
want to use songs they want to use dance
they this is not a theater in India that
a lot of Samba music is universal it's
the universal language speaks to
everyone so not the ladies there
suggested using songs and they also
wanted to include religious themes and
how they do that but we are they wanted
to that as well they once is a live
audition they wanted a context to
include and they share some very
touching anecdotes with me I mean they
talk about what their friends will to
deliver all the way to the hostel and
remember the rulinea the nearest
hospital was 14 kilometers away and the
woman and many times we're going to
river in the in the vehicle that I
driving to in driving in and they also
said that they didn't have a midwife so
I have been trying to figure I can get
away by training of them if not we just
have include some components in
operating manual entry and they also
suggested that's nothing for interesting
fact we do in the moment some we do have
a government clearly of workers an
adventure mentioned but they won workout
covers two thousand people so you know I
think if we trained and trained many
more she has some supplemental support
stop thinking of her again they want to
clean it is looking to upgrade it for
them
I hope she can find it will help me okay
so we're ready to do this over there
we're ready to implement the manual we
just need to include a few more pictures
of salvation people is there they want
it to be somehow gestures well it's not
anybody's said if they were okay most of
them were fine with the hand gesture
except Allah to which may be enact me we
may have to work on and they want to
change the source of employment for them
eventually and i think is the
possibility because i did speak to a
couple of nonprofits over there and we
get amends by sweeping up meetings and
again some very innovative ideas and how
to do that which I'll show you right now
I don't love me like being reproductive
health component and yeah visuals
pamphlets for people who are from
different different age groups with a
lot of visuals in it and some women's
dresses had a sour coming vending
machine with Mary and get us pretty much
it I'm just go in do you only the slide
and that Wallace I just want to thank
you so much for giving me this
opportunity and I want to try to
research group on health disparities and
iteration foundation and not to be in
your permission are the two particles
that we have in India and 45 seconds and
you can see there yeah and they have a
message for you dr. Wallace I just
ok maybe not obviously trying to say is
it we're ready with waiting for you to
come back and give up the chances of the
trainee they're generally of your great
the only is it like a call that we do
very often we do that to God also we can
able to God a lot also basically it's a
cause to do to took action things you
know maybe it is very nice possible for
us you know music like I said it works
wonders ok so it's all say all together
the preceding program was brought to you
by Teachers College Columbia University
please visit us online at iTunes TC
columbia edu